all sorts of different right-wing media
types on the internet have increasingly
been talking about a civil war a civil
war that they believe is coming and in
some sense a civil war that some of them
seem to actually be welcoming and
whether it is because of those
individuals
or for other reasons we now have two in
five americans roughly 40 percent of
americans who believe that within the
next decade there is going to be another
civil war here in the united states now
when we say civil war and united states
what we think back to is the civil war
in the united states of course in the
19th century which was a war essentially
over slavery it was between the union
and the confederacy the union which
wanted to end slavery and the
confederacy which wanted to keep it now
there's been revisionist history which
has been done
to
sort of glorify the confederacy or at
least make it seem more benign and
usually the way that's done is they say
it's not about a war to keep slavery
it's a war for states rights a
fundamental conservative value and sure
if what the states wanted a right to do
was to keep slavery legal then so be it
but really it wasn't about slavery it
was about states rights now that's bs
doesn't we don't have to get into more
detail but that is the the false story
that many of those who i guess today
would still be on the side of the
confederacy uh like that's the story
they like to tell about the first civil
war and now we have an economist yougov
poll wherein 40 percent of americans
believe we are heading towards another
civil war now let's look at a couple of
the different things that are in this
poll
first and foremost
do americans expect political divisions
and violence to increase over the next
few years
and the answer is that on political
divisions
two-thirds of americans believe we will
be more politically divided
and that uh political division is likely
to increase and on political violence 65
percent believe that political violence
um
has increased and looking ahead 62
believe it will continue to increase now
what is the partisan split here this is
very very important for those who say
that in the last year and a half the
country has become
more divided
republicans are more likely than
independents and democrats to say that
now what has happened during that time
well a democrat joe biden became
president of the united states the mere
presence of biden they believe has made
the country more divided and if you look
at looking ahead do you think the amount
of political division is more likely to
increase stay the same or decrease it is
republicans more than democrats that
believe political division will increase
but it's not a big difference this is
actually quite interesting because it's
only a 14-point split
the country is mostly on the same page
both republicans and democrats 58
percent of democrats think there will be
more political division
and 72 percent of republicans it is a
difference but it is not a dramatic
partisan difference now
on the issue of civil war this is very
very important and disturbing take a
look at these numbers um
among adult
citizens in general
43 percent say it is very or somewhat
likely that there will be another civil
war in the next 10 years
and this is where the partisan split is
somewhat more significant
among democrats those for example who
are strong democrats
40 percent believe a civil war is very
or somewhat likely whereas among strong
republicans 54 believe a civil war
is very or somewhat likely that is a
significant difference but also it's not
like the 70 20 type thing you know you
there are questions you can ask
people
and the partisan split is significantly
more dramatic i'm struggling to think of
which ones they would be but you know on
issues related to for example guns
sometimes you see a massive partisan
split 14 points on civil war is not like
a dramatic split
now where i believe you would see a
significant difference would be if you
ask folks
what do you believe would cause such a
civil war what do you believe would
cause such a civil war
my instinct is and this is something
that you would have to do a poll on if
you ask the left-wingers what do you
think would cause the civil war
i think most left-wingers would say
right-wingers launching a civil war
and if you asked the right-wingers what
would cause a civil war
i think they would mostly say
the left-wingers would cause a civil war
in other words i think in different
terms
you would see both the left and the
right say that it would be the right
that would precipitate and take action
on that civil war the leftists would say
the right-wingers are going to do it
because they don't like the ways in
which society is changing and the
right-wingers would say we had no choice
because look at what the leftists were
doing to our country
very different moral frameworks in terms
of who is responsible
but i think it would be in a sense
an agreement in that it would be the
rightists who actually launch it and the
writers would say well we had no choice
because of what the leftists have done
to this country
not particularly pleasing numbers i mean
when nearly half the country thinks in
the next decade there will be a civil
war
it doesn't seem to be boding
particularly well we're going to follow
these numbers and it would be good to
have other polling as well because it is
increasingly a topic i mean later in the
show actually
we're going to have a clip of conspiracy
theorist alex jones who just got dinged
for 49 million in a defamation suit
he seems to be trying to precipitate
that civil war and is predicting it i
think within the i think he said in 71
days oddly specific but we'll get to
that alex jones clip a little bit later
on in the show
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com pacman you
will get aura free for 14 days which you
can use to do things like see if your
passwords have been leaked the link is
down below